jetzt geht es um ein thema was viele
viele autofahrer umtreibt sie werden
tyrannisiert kann man fast sagen seit
wochen ja seit monaten von einer kleinen
gruppe von klimaaktivisten die sich
einfach auf die straße kleben hören sie
und schauen sie selbst
wird so nicht mehr gitarre aber ich kann
nicht aufstehen gerade lassen sie mich
ich kann nicht stehen lassen aufrufen
können aufstellen das kann nicht
dastehen
du kannst einfach konstanter kommen so
hunger nicht aufstehen wenn wir
weiterhin forcieren waren sind jetzt
weiter nach öl bohren heute h
warum
ja denn sie
wahnsinnig
und jetzt gehts aber kommen
doch schnell sicher
geograf run ist das noch klimaschutz ist
das noch kampf für den klimaschutz oder
ist das schon mehr ist er schon tyrannei
also ihr leben mit einem regelbasierten
start es sind regeln ihres zusammenleben
organisieren
und dazu gehört dass jeder das recht zur
warme sonne richter hat und wenn ein
autofahrer auf der straße fährt hat er
ein ziel der möchte er hinkommen und
nicht gestört werden werden nicht
unfälle und ähnliches passieren durch
dritte die meinen sie haben die moral
gepachtet und die lösung aller welt
probleme und sich auf dessen auf die
straße kleben
wissen sie das sind in berlin drei
notarzt wagen mussten umkehren weil und
war eine der geburt befindet die frau
sondern herzinfarktpatienten
patientin und einem unfallopfer und da
mussten die sich durch die sozusagen
betroffenheits kultur oder demonstranten
mühsam durchkämpfen um dann vielleicht
irritiert zu erreichen hier hört der
spaß auf hier werden regelverstöße
gemacht im namen einer für sich
gepachtet höheren moral wenn das jeder
machen würde es gibt auch noch andere
gruppen stellen sie sich mal vor die die
alle sicher wohlfühlen unterstützen ich
stelle mir vorher wissen sie was ich mir
vorstelle ein fdp-politiker oder fdp
politiker die für den diesel kämpfen den
verbleib des dieses auf deutschen
straßen deren oder abgeschafft werden
soll die würden das genauso machen was
wir dann hier los in diesem land endlich
zu recht ja die kommen nicht auf die
idee weil die regel rechts gezogen sind
und gelernt haben wie man sich benimmt
übrigen haben die zeit aber meist
menschen die das machen ernähren sich
nämlich von staatlichen zuwendungen nach
dem motto von der uni über die
endlos den öffentlichen dienst dann
gleich in den ruhestand das ist also die
eine generation die nur von zu garten
wächst die nicht zum positiven
vermehrung des volksvermögens beitragen
sie mischen aber ein anderes beispiel
sagen ich akzeptiere die ethischen
gründen sehr wohl die dahinter stehen
können nur dann muss das auch in
toleranz gepaart sein was würden sie
denn machen ich nehme an dass sie alles
für diese aktion sind also dem koch als
im gourmet oder vielleicht auch kann man
heute ist alles möglich also dass
wir alle sind für diese aktion einer
beinahe sie nicht das wäre eine der
munters also wenn die da fahren auf der
straße und es wird wirklich gesagt
hiervon haben sich leute geklebt und
dann sind dass frauen die gegen die
abtreibung demonstrieren in den usa sind
dies mehrere zigtausend der sternberg
die frage die über allem schwebt die
menschen leben auf umfragen die kinder
wie er überall tage die deutsche
betrieben es steht 30 ein prozess
klimaschutz über dem gesetz steht der
kampf für klimaschutz vermeintlicher
kampf wie auch immer über dem
grundgesetz also klar 2 kommentare man
sich vorab loswerden weil ich kann mir
wurde noch nie so viel gesagt was ich
wohl denke oder am 19 während sie sich
in der partei die sie anführen weil wir
demokraten sind und da darf ich mich
selber äußern und mir ich werde nicht
einfach eine neue liga rücken würden ich
glaube die zweite sache die ich gerne
richtig stellen würde apropos
rechtsverstöße der afd der die fdp ist
die einzige partei derzeit in
deutschland natürlich außer vielleicht
noch weiter rechtsextremer parteien die
zur zeit vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird ja also das kann ich
nicht beurteilen aber dass die
rechtsverstößen begehen na ja gerade
gesagt das sei die partei die zumindest
rechtskonform erzogen habe oder bringen
sie ja nicht so ineinander bitte das
wurde über diese frau gesprungen zu
machen daraus
nein es wurde
ist gut dass sie das auch noch mal
sprechen erst mal sehr klar das hat
glaube ich nicht die frage ob ein tier
sagt da ist das typisch ist und er ist
ein falscher eindruck so machen die das
ja ich glaube jetzt sind sie aber frau
dran frau sternberg also ich glaube der
klimawandel ist die größte
herausforderung unserer zeit und unserer
gesellschaft ich glaube nicht dass das
in irgendeiner weise rechtfertigt dass
man sich über gemeinschaft
gemeinschaftlich anerkannte gesetze und
richtlinien hinwegsetzen darf überhaupt
gar nicht herzlich willkommen im club ja
genau das ist ja jetzt viele frau daher
kuchen dann haben wir gar nicht mehr zum
surfen oder
auch global betrachten also wir sprechen
davon ja sagt war das sehr traurig für
die drei menschen die im krankenwagen
nicht rechtzeitig angekommen sind im
krankenhaus an denen ich geholfen werden
konnten keiner sie heimlich wir haben
jeden tag zehntausende kinder die
sterben weil es nicht genügend zu essen
haben heißt wenn man auf das thema wo
sich übrigens die un eu und deutschland
committed hat also die wollen ja das
ziel ist es bis 20 30 50 prozent der
lebensmittel verschwendung zu reduzieren
wenn man aber keine taten folgen lassen
auf irgendwelchen gremien diskutieren
sie das in kommissionen bringen sie ja
wissen ein und krakeelen nicht es muss
also dass man sich auch ich muss sagen
also es geht glaube ich am ende darum
wirklich ein konstruktiv irgendwie
vorschläge zu machen wie wir ans ziel
kommen wo fest leben ist kündigt hier
aktiv ist also dass der
versammlungsfreiheit zu demonstrieren
immer wieder auf ein thema aufmerksam zu
machen das hatte ich alles für ganz
wichtige legitime mitte aber zum
beispiel auch bei walt damals im anderen
kontext dann wie gesagt das reicht uns
nicht wir wollen in die gremien wir
wollen in die parlamente
um eben wirklich etwas zu verändern was
mögen sie das werden wir sehen würden
sie sich festkleben erfinden also ich
habe fünf jahre kein geld angenommen
kein geld ausgegeben genau um
aufmerksamkeit zu schaffen und was diese
menschen da geschafft haben dass nicht
nur wir heute über
lebensmittelverschwendung sprechen
sondern in deutschland millionen
menschen dieses thema bewusster geworden
ist und das ist glaube ich ein adäquates
mittel schlagers gerade vorher firma
klebt sich fest und herren ich habe ich
gesagt der hose wir haben wir haben ganz
andere sind wir haben ganz andere
situationen von seinem restaurant
fischers fritz dass wir ungefähr 20 mal
sagen ein restaurant hier mitten in
berlin widerstand haben also dass wir in
einem restaurant mit einem lied am
sonntag gibt's kein gehör weil es gibt
einfach nicht mehr aber es haben sich
aktivisten von der firma peter voß
restaurant stellt haben die gäste gehen
dann ins restaurant hineinzugehen 100
mitarbeiter im monat bezahlt werden muss
ungefähr 20 mal haben das gemacht das
sind 20 riesen ausfälle und dann die
öffentliche schädigung und dann stehen
aber die leute mit witzigen masken und
sie sind der meinung dass sie mit diesen
also demonstrationen ist ein
grundbaustein unserer demokratie keine
frage aber wir müssen natürlich genau
wissen in welchen regeln was ich ihm
auch gesagt haben wir uns zu bewegen
haben allerdings wenn sie uns
wirtschaftlich schädigen wenn sie
unseren ruf schädigen und vor allem wenn
sie uns schädigen und so mitarbeiter mal
dass alle bezahlen zu können da muss ich
ganz klar sagen gehen sie über grenzen
hinaus die einfach nicht machbar sind
und ich würde irgendwann raus haben beim
15 mg mit denen versucht zutaten keine
möglichkeit ich wurde sogar tätlich
angegriffen und dann will ich der
meinung demonstration hat nichts mit
tätlichen angriffs zu tun und deswegen
will man das fest lieber auf der straße
ist nichts anders gewesen als im
restaurant sie haben uns einfach total
geschädigt und wir sind um horst jäger
sondern es ging in gänze stoffe die bei
uns marginal war und es ging darum
fleisch zu verkaufen bitteschön
wir sehen ja auch beim thema letzte
generation das waren ja klima aktivisten
der organisation die sich so nennt
letzte generation immer wieder dass es
rechtsbrüche gibt und dass das also das
wahlrecht für euch getreten wird und das
kann ja eigentlich auch für klima-
aktivisten nicht der weg sein um auf
sich aufmerksam zu machen wenn man
rechtsstaat und der muss doch gelten
genau aber in unserem rechtsstaat ist
zum beispiel egal dass ich einfach ein
tier ermordet und es einfach liegen
lassen es ist total egal ich kann hier
schützt ich darf das machen und wenn ich
aber eine tomate aus einer mülltonne
rausnehmen ist es diebstahl und
hausfriedensbruch in unserem rechtsstaat
und so ist es und trotzdem ist aber
vielleicht global betrachtet wieder bei
machte der weltbevölkerung deren
unternehmen leidet unser wohlstand hier
und wie wir mit lebensmitteln nämlich
umgehen denn die leute sagen die tomaten
seele also ja 70 kilo pro jahr die meist
jeder mensch leute gemacht das ist halt
auch aus meiner perspektive unethisch
und eigentlich auch nicht recht
willkommen seien die sammler aus seiner
perspektive am ende argumentiert immer
zwei dinge aufgreifen die 10.000 kinder
werden wohl nicht die täglich sterben an
unterernährung sterben werden mit
sicherheit nicht weniger gewesen wenn
die drei menschen die vielleicht sogar
gestorben sind ich weiß es nicht nicht
behindert wurden werden sie die
milchmädchenrechnungen dagegen sodass
seinen reihen schaffen nein sie schaffen
ja tatsachen entschuldigen sie dass ich
das wissen die diskussion das zweite ist
mir wirklich wichtig ich habe dinge
gesprochen von leuten die nicht
demonstrieren diese diese fahrer sind da
wurde ich in die nähe der afg gerückt
das ist eine unglaubliche vorgang nein
das ist dass die diffamierung
andersdenkender nach rechtsaußen dass
eine masche die durchgezogen wird sie
glauben damit durch einmal auf ist nicht
legitim entschuldigen sie das vergifte
die diskussionskultur in deutschland
einmal noch mal ganz kurz zu sagen wie
es möglicherweise zu einem jahr oder
sogar zwei missverständnis gekommen ist
ich habe nur gesagt wir haben die
klimaaktivisten auf der einen seite die
menschen tyrannisieren autofahrer und
auf und die frage die gestellt wurde war
ja was würde eigentlich in diesem land
los sein wenn beispielsweise afd
aktivisten oder anhänge oder politikern
von diesel für das ähnlich machen würden
um das war nur der diebe den diesel zu
retten so und sich auch vergeben würden
so das war eigentlich nur das argument
um einmal zu zeigen dass in einem
rechtsstaat und wir würden
wahrscheinlich zu recht
auch bei den fdp-anhängern wie auch
immer alle sagen geht überhaupt nicht es
gibt ein rechtsstaat hier dürft euch
hier nicht festlegen ihr dürft
autofahrer nicht argument schlager gegen
jede form liegt dem fall gab es ein
bisschen gab es hier das ein oder andere
verständnisproblem herr davon ist
natürlich nicht in der nähe der afg das
haben sie auch ganz klar noch mal zurück
genießt leider auch demonstriert wenn
sie zu gelesene zeitung nur das einfach
noch mal glaube ich für jeden zuschauer
klar zu stellen falls es da zu
missverständnissen gekommen ist